I've got breaking news I'm going to show
you in a little bit a letter from an
advertiser that I got who is exposing
what what I don't think there's any term
for it other than a blacklist that is
now existing with regard to the David
Pakman show and another number of other
channels in this YouTube advertiser
boycott so the quick background YouTube
advertiser boycott started about five
days ago after some ads from big
corporations showed up in front of
inappropriate content this is not a
systemic problem on YouTube I would
argue that over the last year the
YouTube ad algorithm has actually been
too strict rather than not strict enough
but the reaction has been countless
advertisers threatening to or actually
pulling out their money from YouTube and
a switch has been flipped the david
pakman show YouTube channel has stopped
making any money this is a systemic
existential crisis for the show which
we've been talking about now for a few
days it has gotten even worse and I'm
going to show you exactly why yesterday
I showed you the revenue destruction
that we had experienced on April 1st 2nd
and 3rd ok and if you look at this
graphic that we're putting up for people
who are watching with us you see that
the last four dots the most recent for
revenue dots are effectively zero and
it's not zero but we basically made six
to ten dollars on each of those days
from YouTube ad revenue okay I have a
new picture which is going to make those
last three days look great this is a
zoomed in graphic now from April 1 to
April 4 and as you can see YouTube ad
revenue for our 14,000 videos which
garnered nearly half a million views on
April 4th was that is not a typo Patt it
is 34 cents the YouTube channel made 34
cents on April 4th because of the
YouTube ad boycott and here is where it
gets even more disturbing I've not seen
any reporting on this yet I believe we
are breaking this I'm going to show you
and read to you a letter from an actual
YouTube advertiser
who is trying
to advertise on the david pakman show
youtube channel and it appears as though
we and other channels including kyle
kolinsky secular talk have been
blacklisted okay here is the letter that
I got and I apologize for the small
print I will try to explain everything
that's going on here
hey David I'm the chick from Twitter
that says I've been advertising on your
channel specifically for a few weeks and
noticed a huge drop in my impressions
over the last couple of days basically i
advertised in front of very specific
channels yours is one of them along with
sam cedar humanist report ring of fire
and secular talk my ads have
consistently had more placements on your
videos than anyone elses yesterday you
fell to the bottom only six impressions
for the day remember we had nearly half
a million views and you were at the
bottom of the list again today with only
five impressions so far today the daily
impressions don't seem to have changed
much for the other channels I advertise
in front of so it was clear that it had
something to do with your channel
specifically I just called and spoke
with customer service at AdWords I spoke
with a great guy who spent a lot of time
looking at things and talking with his
dude at YouTube to see if they could
figure out why the first thing you told
me is what they're telling everyone
they've cracked down especially hard
right now until they figure out how to
fix the situation for everyone fine I
say but that doesn't explain the
disproportionate way this is affecting
Pakman 'el more than the other people
I'm advertising on so he put me on hold
while he talked more with someone from
YouTube and what he thinks could be the
issue is your titles could be considered
more provocative he pointed to words in
your titles like homosexual hate burning
Son of God etc which he said might be
affecting your advertisement placements
he did say that right now things are
much stricter than what they will be
once they get it worked out and that
hopefully the strictness of it will
lighten up but for right now those words
are apparently big no-no words basically
anything that sounds provocative anyway
that's what I know about it hope this
helps just a little love your show okay
so listen
none of our individual videos are
demonetised because of those were
tags or titles our entire Channel
although individual videos are monetized
is not running ads let me say it in a
different way what's going on here
someone is specifically trying to spend
money on our Channel and on Kyle Cole in
Skees channel and on others they are
telling YouTube put my ads on david
pakman channel take my money and put ads
on David Patton's channel and YouTube is
basically saying no the advertiser
preferences don't matter
YouTube has decided no ads on patents
channel and of course the provocative
titles thing is bogus a tiny fraction of
our 14,000 videos have words like these
in the titles here's a list of video
titles that are not running ads
currently you tell me if these are
provocative Trump signs away your
internet privacy whoa if a kid saw that
Pat their life would be ruined another
video not running ads of course Keystone
XL pipeline won't be built with American
steel do you know how controversial
metal is Pat we talk about steel in that
video here's another video not running
ads turns out rule that blocked Obama's
Supreme Court nominee is not really a
rule here's another one legal scholar
Cass Sunstein on internet echo chambers
and democracy is there anything less
provocative than a lawyer talking about
cognitive biases echo chambers and
democracy here's another video that is
not running ads recommendation Thinking
Fast and Slow by Daniel Kahneman David
Pakman is recommending behavioral
economics books shut it down because if
a Coke ad appeared next to that who
knows what would happen I think the word
thinking is the most controversial in
the whole sentence yet or fast because
things that happen fast could be bad and
then lastly this is just an example
because all 14,000 videos aren't running
ads John Leguizamo might be a david
pakman show fan stop the presses pat
we've got to demonetized that because
john leguizamo he once kissed someone on
camera we can't monetize that and even
those words that that advertiser in
front of the show pointed out things
like homosexual we also know words like
secular right they're going after
religious terms as well that shouldn't
be controversial at this point when I'm
in a day and age where that's accept
by now let me tell you something our
content is so clean because our YouTube
content is the same content that goes
out to our radio stations our show is so
clean that it meets the FCC standards
for non-commercial radio stations which
are bound by the strictest FCC
regulations we have not had one problem
with our show on any of our 200
non-commercial TV and radio stations and
an advertiser trying to advertise on our
channel on YouTube can't do it in the
midst of this our YouTube channel is
killing it in terms of audience I've
been so wrapped up in the fact that 40
percent of our revenue has been cut that
we're up to nearly three hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers on YouTube
and even though it's only the sixth day
of the month we already have three
million views in we're on track for a
record view month on YouTube and our
channel made on April fourth thirty four
cents okay so the urgency of needing
your support is only growing there's no
evidence that the money is going to come
back once again three ways to help our
show number one sign up for membership
at david pakman.com slash membership if
you've done that or even if you haven't
number two help us grow our patreon
following patreon.com slash david pakman
show donate a buck or two we are over
600 patrons I am inspired by the number
of people that have contributed on
patreon let's get to 750 patrons that's
the next goal even if it's only $1 a
month and if it's more by all means
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
number three if you ever shop on Amazon
go to david pakman.com slash amazon
before you shop so by the way just to
show you this is I believe as of an hour
or two ago here's our patreon page 603
patrons 603 people who have said I am
going to publicly make a pledge to send
a little bit of money each month to the
David Pakman show and you can find that
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
I'm inspired by these numbers Pat right
especially because maybe a couple days
ago that number was only a few dozen
they've never already asked 600 amazing
so the immediate next goal is 750
patrons and then we're going on to a
thousand okay so let me know what your
thoughts are about this i'm on twitter
at david pakman
show @d Pakman and please send out on
YouTube the story about the blacklist
that is happening on YouTube many people
don't even know that this is going on
will continue following what's going on
and keeping you abreast of the latest
developments